a liberated woman is one who has sex
before marriage and a job after women
have two choices either she's a feminist
or a masochist chloë grace moretz
is Jesus what a bossy Maggie Nancy in
the shrill voice does it remind you of
Brittany or what you guys okay you
realize that that's a huge compliment
hope my bad Kevin's just bummed because
a cisgender white male is done witness
the future father time hey guys can I
ask you something do your bosses ever
make you ask inappropriate questions I
don't understand the question I once
asked Jennifer Lawrence what her cup
size was you asked her that on camera
I guess my site wants to get into gossip
because number is a little flat they
want me to ask Chloe about who she's
dating
I just feel weird you know as a grown
man asking a young girl about her love
life well is she gonna know if she's
available man okay you guys are all
idiots and you clearly know nothing
about feminism because you're men so
just stick to non-controversial subjects
like her diet secrets or refugees so the
movie oh my god I loved it as a woman
Gloria Steinem has been a huge influence
on me since I googled her half hour ago
I honestly thought like women were
always equal with men you never dealt
with any discrepancy there no because
like in our generation things are
different for us I think we're around
the same age Yeah right like early 20s
I'm sure yep yeah early mid late 20s 30s
I'm 19 okay yeah so like around the same
age are you doing you're doing good
today you look great anyways do you want
to talk about something but we just I
got a little bit of it I'm here
promoting this okay big big one of you
it kind of be like this but that's cool
whatever
oh man you know I'm such a big fan of
all your work like Laura is great but of
course I got to bring up you guys it's
so great cuz Hit Girl is not afraid to
just hit people I don't really agree
with violence it's a movie oh you know
art yeah
it's just that people some of the people
I work with are so mean to me it's like
the prettier they are the meaner they
are if I could be like I mean frankly
she changed the world I think it took
carried away here okay I mean she put a
silly little idea and a lot of girls had
the thing go out there and be the boss
of somebody okay that's not written in
any playbook I know it's not even in the
Bible I mean what a glow glow here
really do when you think about it Wow
first of all no one was even speaking
about menstruation before her you know
what let's just keep this classy okay
you don't need to get disgusting here we
got to put this on TV
you're a Neanderthal you understand that
right
no wonder is is gonna get fired soon all
right Missy I don't think you need to
get rude with me here you literally
can't handle the word vagina uterine
wall Oh God oh I was wrong chloë grace
moretz has the upper hand she's a little
monster we're about ready for you and
just a friendly reminder stick to the
film okay great
hey buddy you owe it to America to keep
them stupid and entertained so go be
that guy okay soldier name and
affiliation Brian Butler the downloaded
oh my god I know you I read your work
you're actually a really good writer oh
wow thanks you've read my work yeah well
you're like a real journalist unlike
those fools out there I mean they're
total clowns they've no idea what
they're doing what do want to ask me so
now that you've had the chance to play a
feminist icon how has that influenced
your outlook on being a woman in today's
society thank you so much you're
actually asking me a question that means
something Gloria came of age in a very
oppressive time it just made me feel
very honored and privileged to be a
young woman in the time period that
we're living in right now such a smart
answer you're such a smart lady who I'm
sure could talk on any number of
interesting subjects yeah I'd love to
you okay yeah no we're probably at a
time right we're good ask me another
question these things usually fly by no
I'm like actually
oh great so I can't I can't get or use
it who are you dating
are you serious I'm just a soldier you
know what I mean like we all do what we
gotta do
I am here doing press for Gloria Steinem
you come in here and you ask me who I'm
Davis sorry
Who am I dating I had marching whores
get out get out of my room
come on move up go you interview me no
no they don't give those do well are you
going by the vending machines